[Music]
that is to say, the term of human rights of
the
world
alvear
pérez
6 plus
such regulations
good afternoon
we had previously come to ask
for marriage to be able to get married and they
told us that we have to have a
human rights charter we already went and well
now we do  They granted us the right to
marry and we want to bring the document
here,
well, good afternoon, welcome to all of
you and note that I have very
good news for you,
you do not need that type of
paper so that you can get married and
bosh a letter from the state
where  They informed us that same-
sex marriages were going to be like
any other marriage,
we are going to put it in, therefore, it is no longer in the business
and updating Verón and Benítez were
lemons as product workers in
immersion,
in which, in their opinion, the change was
because this happened  sudden change I
think there had been many people who have
sought equal marriage and have
been promoting this type  Of
changes,
well, this change occurred in the entire
state or is it only here,
is it in the entire state, any municipality
does not have to deny it
for 10 months, yes, so I can tell you
that we are on the other side now, yes, I am an
accountant, nothing, we are on the  other side and
they tell me
with javier mexico in the report
build the country latin kings that the
gamer and in neiva
you make half sense when
fabricio from the superport runs out of water
the blog
[Music]